in war the enemy is clear but in life in
business not so easy to identify any
tips well I mean first of all that is
not a true statement
and in in war the enemy is not always
clear not at all the enemy the enemy can
be hard to identify very hard to
identify the enemy is gonna use
camouflage to conceal themselves they're
gonna use deception to to distract your
attention they're gonna blend in with
the friendly civilian populace and
they're gonna take advantage of your
benevolence right
in fact the enemy is going to do
absolutely everything in its power to
obscure their position to hide their
purpose to even mask their identity so
it is not easy to identify the enemy in
combat in war so what you have to do is
you have to control what you can control
right you got to be prepared you've got
to train you've got to study
you've got to rehearse you've got to
remain vigilant you've got to maintain
discipline and everything you do so that
when the enemy does reveal itself you
have the ability to think it to out
maneuver to out fight the enemy and it's
actually the same thing in business
right the enemy can be hard to identify
your competitors aren't broadcasting
their next move you don't know what the
markets gonna do you can't be certain
about the next trend or the next
downturn or the next bubble that's gonna
burst you can't know those things so you
have to do the same thing if to control
what you can control which is you gotta
gather intelligence you got to analyze
the metrics that you can track you've
got to
train yourself and your team to be
prepared for both the known and also be
prepared for the unknown figure out what
the likely contingencies are then have
some plans to execute if those
contingencies occur maintain discipline
as an organization so that you have the
flexibility and the responsiveness to
maneuver effectively and efficiently
when the unpredictable actually happens
so instead of suffering and falling
apart in the chaos you can take
advantage of it and win and that's
business and life is the same the enemy
is not always clear in life it can be
hard to tell who's gonna try and bring
you now or what is going to bring you
down there's distractions there are
things out there that will do you harm
that are so camouflaged you can't see
them at all there are deceitful people
there are accidents that can occur and
diseases that take root and there's bad
luck and there's Murphy's Law and
there's times when it seems that the
whole world is against you the whole
world is the enemy and the same rules
apply
control what you can't control
you train hard learn maintain the
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things train hard physically and
mentally push yourself so hard that you
become accustomed to the stress you get
used to it
every day make yourself stronger and
faster and smarter and better so that
when the enemy does finally climb out of
the shadows and expose himself to you
you are ready you are waiting and you
can relish in the opportunity to attack
and fight and utterly decimate and
destroy him